hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from the final round of the
2019 u.s. championship
now we already mentioned yesterday that
there are three very important games
going on that will most likely not most
like that will decide the victor of the
championship Caruana versus Shanklin
well Shanklin versus Caruana Khurana had
the black pieces
Dominguez versus Timur Gaurav and here
in this game that were just gonna show
Jefferson versus Hikaru Nakamura all
three very important and we are not only
going to show this one but we're gonna
get back to that after I show you the
game and also I did think about trying
to trick you in some way for April
Fool's Day but then again I decided not
to do it you know I don't know or have I
hmm but we'll get back to that let's get
into the game
she hung has the white pieces and he
opens with d4 and what does Nakamura
choose for a game where he definitely
has to win what do you play against d4
well karana had a very successful game -
two runs ago with the Dutch so here a
Nakamura also adopts the Dutch we have
f5 okay Knight to f3 Knight to f6
we have c4 sorry about that and g6 just
the nice main line with g3 by white
Bishop g7 Bishop g2 castles and white
also castles and d6 so you can see the
Dutch although it does expose the the
King a bit too early on the other hand
you do have a very nice dark square
bishop you have a very nice light square
bishop which you can develop and you
don't have all that many problems
developing but you'll see as follows
Knight c3 by Nakamura sorry by Shion the
knight to c6 by Nakamura and now d5
kicking the night either to e5 which
would allow white the double nakamura
spawns or to a5 and here it's not all
that clear how this night will come back
into the game the c6 square is covered
and here b3 defending the c4 pawn an
interesting idea is Queen d3 and just
guarding the c4 pawn preparing b4 to
trap Nakamura's night
but here a black can just go EFI with
the threat of going for and after white
captures on pass on you will
again free the c6 square for blacks
night but an interesting idea after
Knight a5 we have b3
she um defends the c4 pawn and now comes
c5 by Nakamura Bishop to b2 opposing
blacks very strong Bishop and g7 a6
Nakamura is preparing to push b5 and
nice the g5 nice the g5 doesn't really
have all that many squares to go to from
there your knives really gonna go to e 6
maybe maybe she is preparing f3 e4 or
maybe he just want to go tonight h3 to
f4 but you know it's it's a nice square
for the knight also maybe he's testing
if he car is interested in weakening his
position a bit further which he isn't
Nakamura is interested in play on the
Queen side we have looked to be a
preparing b5 and here Queen to d3 just
reinforcing the the b v square and here
nakamura goes Queen e8 I just again
taking care of the be 5 square now b5 is
the idea and here you can go a 4 to
prevent a5 b5 because Knight captures on
b3 obviously so Quinta eh by Nakamura
preparing it and now Knight the d1 she
um finds a different plan
we have finally b5 by Nakamura so it's
very interesting how in this Dutch
Nakamura managed to slow down the play
in the in the center or totally you know
minimize play on the King side and now
he's the one that chooses the character
of the game he decides to put b5 what is
unable to stop it it's just you know a
very successful employment over the
Dutch but okay Queen to d2 attacking the
knight on e5 Knight b7 and now Knights
the e3 we have nice to d8 nakamori
maneuvers denied and well so far white
is still a little bit better but black
black is deciding what the game will
look like so that's a that's a big
accomplishment for Nakamura in the final
round
that he simply must win Knight to h3 by
Shion and now Bishop to d7
we have rook a to d1 and now even before
he ran a Kimura decided to close off the
B file and now he wants to play a5 a4
bust open
along the a file then perhaps called
Roque eight maybe maybe drop the rook or
all the way down we'll see how it goes
Queen to c2 by Shion now comes a five
preparing a four Knights the f4 and now
Nakamura
does push the pawn all the way to a four
we have H for preparing Bishop to f3 and
h5 trying to make something happen on
the King side rook to e8 preparing to
catch one B to capture on b3 Queen to be
one and now rook the a6 just improving
the position keeping the tension getting
the rook out of this nasty diagonal as
if the position somehow opens up you
don't want to constantly be looking
looking over your shoulder for that
Bishop Bishop to f3 like we said h5 is
the idea
Queen to f7 by Nakamura and now Knight
eat the G to first we have Knight to g4
now Nakamura wants to trade the dark
square Bishop sand also trade Queens and
go straight into the endgame here you
could go efore immediately but chun
first decides the double Nakamura's jeep
on with the shock captures pawn captures
and only now play E for at the further
enforce the center Nakamura trades
better capture screen captures and Queen
g7 offers a trade of Queens and if you
don't trade Queens then Nakamura will
simply have his queen on this longest
diagonal on the board which will be a
huge success for black
so she um decides to trade with Queen
captures keen captures and now II five a
very nice breakthrough by white because
if black captures then 93 you will start
picking up the pawns and well you've
you've severed one of the links of the
pawn chain and now the pawns become weak
after E 5 you don't want to allow East 6
so your Bishop will be closed in push up
to f5 by nakamura
a very nice square for the bishop and
now again if you close it then that
doesn't really go in White's favor yes
it's a very advanced pawn but it's not
all that clear how white will make use
of it black will just go 97 a capture on
b3 go R okay three make some 995 moves
pile up on the beat three four maybe
even Bishop c2 is an idea attack the
pawn from behind so not
really something white would favor from
we have eke actress and v6 instead we've
each capture some v6 and now rook F 2 e
1 preparing rook to e7 and here nakamura
could prevent it with King to f7 but
then it's not all that clear how you
would make use of the rook so here
Nakamura decides to go night f7 he
allows the rook to infiltrate on the
seventh rank this is not a lot of people
would do this I imagine you have to be a
very strong player to actually allow
this rook to e7 by Shion immediately
going after that seventh rank and now
King to have six pushing the rule back
we look to b7 and now just a capture son
b3 a capture son b3 and rook FTA it's
not allowing something like rook rook e1
to e7
Nakamura's idea is to player ok one
trade off one of the rooks and now yes
white does have a orokin b7 which is
usually a fantastic thing but here the
rock doesn't really have all that many
targets ok and the knight cannot move
whoops sorry about that
then I cannot move for the moment as you
would lose this pawn but that pawn can
simply move and okay with Knight the e3
going after the bishop on f5 as it's
just a wonderful piece rook to e1
offering a trader brooks king to f1 she
improves the position of the of the King
and now Knight to e5 going after that
very nice F 3 square root capture
suddenly one rook captures an a1 with
check and now King to e2 getting out of
check in the now Knight to f3 and here
you have to be very careful already
Nakamura has some deadly plans in mind
if you play something silly like rook
captures on h7 do you see how black wins
of course you do
why black is covering the d3 square so
rook to e1 will be checkmate the white
king has nowhere to go so you can see
how powerful the bishop is a white
decides to eliminate it with Bishop
kasoori Knight captures on f5 King
captures on f5 and this is a very
important moment it seems that pawn
captures on f5 is the you know normal
thing to do you want double your pawns
you just enjoy a better position not
really this is a forced to draw because
white can just go Knight h5 and you
don't have anywhere to go
the rook covers this
the the pond covers this if you go g6
then night back to f4 check and if you
go King here then King III now white
threatens checkmate with rook to e7 and
but not allowed check maybe black would
have to settle for rook e1 check in d3
again you threaten checkmate Ruby one
check you would have to repeat moves
constantly to avoid this very nice
checkmate so although this seems like
the way to go and Nakamura odd opts for
the best choice King captures an f5 not
allowing nights to come to h5 King to
III by white now comes Luke to e1
forcing the King back King the d3 and
now knights the e5 check forcing the
King back King the d2 and here Nakamura
played rook to a 1 although everyone
thought that he would go rook to be one
because you just start winning pawns
yeah you attack at this point and then
after the King defends it now you just
switch over to this pawn and now you
start picking off for all the points
here on the King side Nakamura finds a
different plan first he goes you look to
a 1 it's a similar plan she only goes
Knights the e6 we have h6 save saving
the pawn and now look the b6 to going
after this base of the pawn chain rook
to a3 now going after the b3 pawn king
to see to defending and only now rook to
a to check King to d1 and now comes
Knight to d3
now really controlling the entire
seventh rank the White King really
doesn't have anywhere to go and now best
of all the the black King can start
infiltrating the position rook captures
and d6
it's a pawn grab but there is nothing
better Knight captures I have to check
King to e1 and now tonight back to d3
check King to d1 and kinked efore
finally the black King manages to get in
there and if you know the King gets even
closer for example to the 6th rank then
all sorts of checkmating ideas become
possible here
Knight c7 preparing to at least drop
some checks towards the black king but
Knight F to check King to e1 kink to d3
now the black King successfully
infiltrates and then our roof to g6
again it's a pawn grab but White has
nothing better
94
now we have King to f1 and now Knight
captures and g3 with check King to g1
and now Knight to e2 check King to h1
and now comes King to e3 Shion prevents
the the black King from approaching the
white king he he you know cuts it off
with rook to f6
but now rook to a1 check King to g2 and
now comes look the g1 check King to h2
and now comes g3 check we have King to
h3 and here Nakamura just played rock to
h1 and it was in this position that
Geoffrey Sheung resigned to the game and
Nakamura was successful in winning his
his last round game you lose because if
you go King g4 then g2 there's no way to
prevent the pond from queening and it's
interesting what happens if King to g2
then it's the force checkmate feel free
to pause the video here and try to find
it this a very nice forcing sequence
while I have a nice tip of my water for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
checkmater in for and well you have also
just won the US Championship and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show the idea is rookie to check King f1
now you go G to check King has to go to
e1 and now rook h1 check and after do
you only move that is rook blocks now
you can choose how you want to deliver
checkmate
do we want to capture with the rook do
we want to capture with the pawn bring a
queen into the game do you want to maybe
bring a rock into the game all sorts of
checkmates are possible so you know you
can just enjoy Geoffrey of course did
not want to wait after up to h1 he
resigned and it was a it was a really
well thought game but you know two times
in this tournament Nakamura plated and
he and Khurana plated the Dutch defense
prevailed so you know it's it's it seems
that anything goes these days but yeah I
have prepared the final standings for
those of you who are interested here it
is
it's from chess 24 website I'll also put
a link to it in the description below
there we have it Nakamura with 8 points
half a point ahead of Dominguez Perez
linear and Fabiana caruana with seven
and a half points so Hikaru Nakamura is
the 2019 US chess champion
we have done a linear dominguez and
Fabiano Caruana
with seven and a half points with six
points Wesley so when Samuel seven
Samuel Shanklin with five and a half
last year's winner
with five points Jeffery hyung after
losing this game in the Wonderland
we have Alexander Linderman Varro's and
could be an auntie Margaret with four
and Rhea Robson with three and a half I
also decided I will for one more game it
is definitely a linear Dominguez versus
a team or grave the the game that was
also one of the games that could decide
the winner of the championship is just
really really awesome so I'm sure you're
gonna enjoy that as well
and yeah that's pretty much it for this
game if you haven't do check out the the
trailer for the Greinke just classic
once again I will put a link to it the
first thing you will see in the
description below I would like to thank
George shot see Georgie a guru brain
Schmitt Marcos David Allen ferns and
Michael Hildebrand for a contribution to
my channel think your water really
appreciate it
Michael Hildebrand is one of the first
contributors to this channel so I'm very
very happy to see that you are still
enjoying the content as usual you can
check too on my previous videos here
think all for watching and I will see
you soon with some more interesting
content and there is one very very
special video coming today so I do hope
you're ready for that thank you and I'll
see you soon have an excellent start of
your week